[Music]
by its as these I'm sorry this is what's
in my bag that I brought to Paris
headphones a very ambitious three books
recently I have somehow started reading
because I took internet off my phone and
my computer so I'm reading this book of
Fellini interviews that I got in this
cool bookstore in the East Village meet
me in the bathroom which is kind of
about the whole early two-thousands
strokes yeah as LCD Soundsystem I was in
New York in that time and I wish I was
interviewed so I could tell them all the
uncool stuff I was doing in New York at
that time as well homo Deus the guy got
a quote from Barack Obama on the back of
his book people call me for quotes for
the back of books this guy called Obama
to film cameras I always travel with
these contacts t3 it's a great camera
and I usually load this with black and
white film and then I have this one the
Olympus Stylus epic which I put color in
I love the pictures for these cameras
what else we have I have sunglasses I
have this little pouch where I have this
very sad version of that James Bond
thing where I have currency from
different countries I have some pounds I
have some yen I have some dollars and a
bunch of change which I need to just put
in some donation bin after I finish this
explanation stop watch the video you
install an application to prevent
yourself and having internet access
except for 30 minutes a day during those
30 minutes you look up whatever you want
you read whatever one give yourself an
hour if you need to but the rest of the
day you have no internet and you try to
force yourself to change your mind to
reach for a book to read
by
[Music]